good morning everyone and
welcome to our first session for omnics
logic transcriptomics
today in this session we will review the
program
make sure that everybody is set up and
ready to go
and for those of you that are joining us
for the first time you'll get an
introduction to what transfer comics is
all
about omix logic transcriptomics
is an online training program for
students researchers
and clinicians it is designed to
introduce participants to the various
aspects of rna-seq data analysis
in application to basic research
biotechnology
and biomedical projects and you'll see
that we'll talk today about
rna-seq in application to cancer
research
infectious diseases and biotechnology
but we'll take a perspective
from the data point of view
so omixlogic programs were designed in
collaboration
between pine biotech which is a big data
analytics company based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design so as a result the
omixlogic programs
have been thoroughly tested by both
faculty
and students and we now know that they
lead to excellent outcomes for students
and faculty
that are interested in bioinformatics
data science
and biomedical research one of our
primary collaborating institutions
is that university of haifa and
primarily the tower bioinformatics
research center
but also some of the other institutions
that we've worked with
are both in the us and around the world
for those joining us for the first time
my name is elia brodsky i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
our vision is to enhance human health
and well-being
by enabling biological research and
discovery
with relevant data solutions and support
our mission is to simplify
bioinformatics and advance research
through our modular and intuitive
multi-omics data analysis platform
that is powered by human experience and
artificial intelligence
we offer training research support
and big data analytics tools designed
for research and biomedical discovery
that does not require technical
expertise
our mission is to support cutting-edge
research
and solve big data challenges by making
our solutions easy to use
and train those interested to use them
to arrive at sound
and reproducible results i'm honored to
have been working with people that have
much more experience in this area than
myself including the other co-founders
of the company dr alfred tauber
who comes from a medical background with
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of inflammation
he has a long-standing recognition for
his generous support of many
international projects and research
activities
one of these projects is the
establishment of the tower
bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
and a close collaborator in numerous
research projects
dr lenin brodsky is the director of the
tower bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career has developed multiple novel
algorithmic approaches
to biomedical and basic biological data
research
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research projects in
biotechnology
pharmaceutical r d agriculture and
biomedical research
what we will discuss today is also a
result of hard work by some of the
people
that are mentioned here on the left
julia panoff
who is an expert bioinformatician and
has helped prepare many of the materials
that we will utilize
avi titivski who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of the t-bind
for platform that we will use
mohit mazumder who is in charge of
business development for pine biotech
joshua mckindle who maintains the
educational web portal that we will
leverage
and vipsa biswas our online community
manager and support specialist
who i'm sure that many of you have
already interacted with and will
continue to interact with throughout
this program
i also want to introduce you to dr
paprika together with me
she will be co-hosting some of the
sessions
and she is a certified omnics logic
trainer which means that she has
completed
a phd in bioinformatics but also
completed all of the training resources
that we will utilize and has helped
develop some of them
to make them adaptable to these online
training sessions
as i mentioned she has a phd in
bioinformatics and her focus was on
cancer genomics
and she has a lot of experience working
with transcriptomic data
she will help conduct some of the
sessions and work with each one of you
as a mentor and a support specialist she
can answer
questions about any of the pipelines
that we will run
if you face any issues with files
settings
formats she's also an experienced
researcher herself with many
peer-reviewed publications
that she contributed to or has led
independently
so if any one of you has research
questions you're also welcome to
set up the time to discuss with her and
we'll go through those technical details
in the near uh in in the following
slides so before we continue
i wanted to make sure that all of you
that are here today
have completed setting up your accounts
uh i i see that we have quite a number
of you here
on um on this session
so let's go together to
edu dot t bio dot info
this is a website where we will
add different types of materials for you
to go through
so please go with me to edu to uh
that info and please let me know once
you are here you can simply post in the
chat
that you're there or yes or something
like that so i will know
okay so once you're here if you have
already completed your registration
you should be able to see that you are
logged in just like you see right here
for me
i can see my profile and i will use
for a second dr harpreet's profile as an
example
of a completed profile
okay so if you click on the right corner
and you get to your profile
you will see that your profile has
an avatar doesn't have to be your
personal picture
but it can be some kind of an avatar so
we can easily find you
you can also add some social media links
uh to your profile this is good for
communicating with others that are also
going to be participating in this
program
you can even add your research accounts
here as well
and if you would like you can add a
little bit of information about you so
as you can see right here
uh dr karpoor has added some information
about her research background and
interests and she also has a faculty
position which
is an rmx logic bioinformatics trainer
now what will happen throughout this
program is on this account
you will see how all of your activity is
going to accumulate
to demonstrate your progress this means
that any courses that you will
go through you will get certificates for
any exercises that we that we will do
you will also see them appear here under
activity
these will include pipelines that you
run and
coding exercises that you complete so
please make sure that you
finalize your account you can do it
during the session
or after this session so you can see
here for example dr kaur has completed
introduction to metagenomics
or has run specific pipelines this will
help you keep track of where you are
and also will help us evaluate whether
we are going through the material too
fast or too slow
and make sure that everybody is staying
on track
now to get access to all of the
resources for this program
if you have completed the registration
you will have access to
this organization page so this
organization
page is the page where we will
centralize
all of the resources associated with
this program
the way to get there an easy way to get
there and remember this link
is just by going over to events
and you will see that this is the first
program that appears right here on the
left omics logic transfer domain so if
you click there
you will get to this program and what
you will see
is the schedule of upcoming sessions
as well as the updates from all the
participants for example
pipelines that have been run or course
work
that has been completed and
exercises in coding that have been
completed so again
we will review these in the interactive
sessions
but you will also see all of that come
up here
also this program page
has a forum and
this forum includes
okay let's go to the forum this forum
includes important announcements
that will have reference publications
for the material
that we will review in the sessions it
will have session recordings
as well as any technical questions so
the most efficient way
to communicate with us and especially if
it is relevant for the rest of the
participants
the best way to talk about these is by
posting
a forum question right here
if you have trouble with a specific
course or a specific pipeline or a
specific assignment
you can also reference those by pasting
your url
an image or a video so that we can
clearly see what the problem is
so in this program we will see how
relying on
analytical methods and reference
databases
researchers can study rna-seq data
to understand how gene expression
variation
happens across many conditions to do so
effectively
bioinformaticians leverage big data
processing methods
organized into bioinformatics pipelines
perform
exploratory data analysis and
normalization
and then apply statistical methods for
rigorous hypothesis testing
and this is what's called standard
rna-seq so what we will hope to cover
in this program are methods for
data processing exploration
statistical analysis and we'll also
touch on machine learning
because we are moving into the age of
big data where large
biomedical research data sets are
available for mining
and classification at the end of the
program we will also speak about
single cell rna-seq which is a hot topic
and an important one as we try to
understand how disease is manifested in
different tissues
organs and cells but before we jump into
all of these specific
types of sessions that we have scheduled
let's do a little overview of what next
generation sequencing can help us
understand and how does that correlate
with the biology of what we are studying
onyx technologies like next generation
sequencing can be used to explore the
roles
relationships and actions of the various
types of molecules that make up the
cells
of an organism many types of omics data
can be generated using next generation
sequencing or what is also known
as high throughput sequencing the data
can show
detailed information about genomic
variants and patterns of gene and
isoform expression
so when we think about a cell we are
thinking typically about its phenotype
and collectively different ways to
categorize and characterize
phenotypic properties can be referred to
as
phenomics here you can see a microscope
image
of cells that reveal cell morphology
and different physiological properties
that help us characterize this specific
type of a cell line
but this type of cell line this
phenotype
is based on how the
processing of dna happens and so when we
talk about
genomics we are talking about the
genetic code
that encodes specific genes and
coding sequences that regulate how
this phenotype appears along the way
from the genotype to phenotype
we encounter what's called epigenetic
regulation
that is regulation that affects gene
expression
but is not necessarily encoded in the
dna
and then we go to transcriptomics and
that is really the study
of how to quantify different types of
coding sequences from the dna that are
being
transcribed or expressed and that
will help us estimate approximately
what kinds of proteins are being
produced
but the proteins themselves are not
exactly what is encoded in the dna so it
is a proxy
for expression of proteins and we will
primarily focus
on the aspect of protein coding mrnas
or messenger rnas
so as a method of measuring rna
translation
transcriptomic studies can help detect
mrna expression
inside the cell as an accurate
alternative
to membrane protein expression detection
which allows for molecular precision in
diagnostics
and even development of treatment based
on molecular pathways
so when we speak about transcript atomic
or
transcription data we're talking about
the process
of mrna being in
the act of translation which helps us
estimate the resulting protein
expression
now in biomedical studies this is a
useful alternative to measuring protein
abundances
and so we will see how that is used in
many different types of biomedical
applications
rna sequencing or rna-seq has
revolutionized the way biologists
examine transcriptomes and has been
successfully applied in biological
research
drug discovery and clinical diagnostic
development
compared with microarray-based
transcriptome profiling
rna-seq has a wider dynamic range
which means that it can detect a wider
type of variation
and avoid some of the technical
limitations such as varying pro
performance and cross hybridization
rnac can measure the expression levels
of thousands of genes simultaneously
and provide insights into functional
pathways
and the regulatory networks and
biological systems
in addition rnac can provide novel
insights into alternative splicing
unannotated exons and novel transcripts
most importantly such detail has already
proven to yield
significant discoveries in many research
areas
so let me pause here and i wanted to ask
a few questions
about your personal background so
you might be coming from a biological
research background
from clinical research background maybe
you're in industry
or perhaps you're a student and you're
still undecided about
where you're going so can we take a few
minutes and
talk a little bit about what is your
background so you can for example put in
i'm a masters student
and i'm studying uh let's say biomedical
informatics or something like that
and and the other question that i have
is really where you are from
so you can mention your country uh your
city and country
or even the continent the continent that
you are from
and you can type your responses in the
chat box so i'll put mine in
all right thank you andrea um clinical
research statistical development applied
research phd in clinical community
psychology with emphasis in quantitative
psychology usc okay bachelor's degree
student studying medical laboratory
science in nigeria
uh aisha is a medical laboratory science
student
undergraduate at hebrew is a
bachelor's degree by chemistry and
molecular biology in kenya
raju is a master's computer science
student
in india david is a post-doc
at the massachusetts general hospital in
boston biomedical research on
autoimmune diseases okay great
aisha is a medical laboratory science
student
from nigeria in africa nan kunsan is a
lecturer in medical
technology in thailand amhc
18 is a bachelor's in molecular biology
from university of south florida
taking a course because of interest in
genomics and epigenetics
and marek is a co-working in research by
technology all right great
so thank you for sharing that
information devo
cancer researcher masters graduate in
biology from kerala india
manojit is a masters in zoology fishery
science from kolkata
india felicia is a microbiology lecturer
from nigeria africa
okay excellent so we have here a lot of
different locations francisco ferreira
is a veterinary scientist with phd in
parasitology from brazil
working with vector-borne diseases at
rutgers university in usa
krupa and matthew is a phd degree holder
in biotechnology from
uh treven drum india excellent so we
have many different locations
it's exciting to see all of you joining
today so let's
talk a little bit about um okay
ng is also a phd in bioinformatics from
the uk
great so what type
of applications are there
for bioinformatics in these different
applications really what we will focus
on
in this program is how can gene
expression
and the patterns contained in such data
can be associated with clinical
phenotypes or clinical data
and help us identify molecular
biomarkers or
specific types of patterns that can be
useful
for diagnosing disease selecting
therapies for different patients
and even identifying targets for
specific types of treatments
so the type of data is really
a view of a particular type
of biological phenomena
but the way to use this uh specific data
and the patterns contained in the data
is driven by the application so as we
discuss
these different types of data we should
consider that it has applications in
many different domains
and that's why one of the ways that we
will
apply uh rna-seq analysis approaches
is to look at specific projects and so
as we look at these projects
please keep in mind that agriculture
neuroscience cancer other types of
applications
are all going to be related to whatever
project
you can find and the easiest way to find
a project
and start thinking about the
applications of rna-seq
in the area of your interest is to start
exploring publicly available data so one
of the important things that we'll do in
this program
is we will introduce you not only to the
theory
and the tools for rna-seq data analysis
but we will also
go and find different types of data sets
that you can start
analyzing so some of these projects that
we will explore
include diagnostics and cancer biology
and specific we'll talk about
the relationship between tumor and the
tumor micro environment
we'll talk about different types of
clinical phenotypes of
different types of cancers we'll also
talk about
disease classification and patient
stratification
which is a way to define disease not
based on clinical observations but
really based on molecular
manifestations of those diseases which
also help us
helps us understand variability in the
patient population
and we'll also talk about single cell
and tissue composition because we will
explore how disease is manifested in
different tissues in different ways
and it's important for us to really link
those molecular
patterns that we discover at the
individual cell type level
so to summarize in this program
we will focus on specific topics
that will combine the logic of analysis
with some practical hands-on assignments
and repeating those assignments in
sessions like these
that will allow you to understand and
practice methods of analysis
and interpretation of rna-seq data and
use them in real world exam samples that
we will find
in publicly available data sets so at
the end of this program
you should be able to plan how to go
from
raw data and we'll talk about several
different formats
of the data that we start from then go
through the steps of processing and
exploring that data
and then understanding how to identify
relationships between what we find in
the data
from sequencing and some phenotype that
will lead to biological
interpretation and we will be able
to plan how to apply such methods
to a project of your own knowing where
to find specific types of data and then
plan
our bioinformatic analysis so before we
move on
let's make sure that we understand the
schedule so to understand the schedule
of this program
for those of you that are registered we
already looked
at the at the specific program page
which was right here and you can
look on the home page to find all of the
sessions
but we can also look at the schedule
right here at the registration page so
for those of you that have not yet
completed your registration
i recommend going to this
link okay and andrea are this
is asking are the slides for each
workshop available for note-taking
so what will happen after each session
is we post the video
and it will be found right here on the
forum
you will have a special section that
will say session recording so all the
videos will be posted there
now a lot of the material that we will
talk
through is also found in specific
courses and i will get to that in just a
second
okay so for those of you that are um
coming to this program just to explore
right now i just wanted to point your
attention
right here you have the specific
sessions that are being planned
and the dates and what they will cover
so please review
this schedule and based on the schedule
you can also find
some of the resources that come together
with the program because
the sessions that we have are just the
glue
that kind of links all the different
elements together but we have a lot of
other
things that we have prepared for you to
look through
one of the important things that are
included are online asynchronous courses
that you have access to as a part of
this program
and some starter projects so these are
projects that are based on
published uh peer-reviewed publications
and they allow you to see how the
rna-seq data is used
in all kinds of uh different
applications
you will also get access to a big data
analysis platform
that allows you to quickly process data
and have access to multiple different
types of algorithms that
are somewhat cumbersome to install on
your own machine
and definitely time consuming to run so
it will give you
practical experience working with these
different types of algorithms
without having to have huge resources at
your disposal
and really a complicated
tutorial to install all of those we will
also practice some of the analysis
methods
on a coding platform that we developed
that will allow us to do it
together during these interactive
sessions
okay so for any of you that are having
questions about
registration or any kinds of payment
options or others
please email to marketing at pine.bio
and just seeing some
messages here in the chat so i'm just
going to put uh
this marketing at pine dot bio so you
can email
any of your questions about registration
or access to any of these tools to
marketing at pine dot bio
or vipsa thank you vipsa for posting
your
email here as well you can reach out to
her on chat
privately to also discuss those options
as well
so as i mentioned on this page you will
find all the details related to
registration
access to different resources as well as
the schedule and once you have completed
you will have access
to this program page on this program
page we will post
any kinds of additional reference
materials for you to go through
because as we go through some of the
resources in the program
there will be additional reading
materials like publications that review
the methods that we discuss
there will be projects that we will go
through and we'll post links to those
project data sets
and so all of that will be right here on
this program page
at the end of the program you will see
that your profile
is going to start to improve and you
will start seeing points
for different types of activities that
you perform
for example after completing a pipeline
after going through quizzes after going
through
a course you will start seeing that you
have
an activity tab with the total number of
courses with the pipelines that you've
run
and importantly for each one of the
sessions
sorry for each one of the asynchronous
courses that we will go through in this
program you will get an independent
certificate
and after completing the whole program
you will also have the ability to get a
certificate of
participation or a certificate of
excellence the certificate of excellence
is really for those
that have done all of the expected
assignments
but also have gone beyond so really uh
to quantify that effort we've uh put a
number to it and it's about
10 000 points so as you see your points
accumulating
you will know that after you've crossed
10 000 points that's when you get
to a certificate of excellence
now the program as i mentioned is
composed of these several different
elements
they are interactive zoom sessions like
we are doing today
they include a lot of self-guided study
materials and those self-guided study
materials
will be available on the educational
platform as well as
the omixlogic platform i'll go through
those in a second
but inside of those there will be some
very practical assignments that include
running pipelines and exploring the
outputs of those pipelines
and also some coding exercises the
coding exercises
are not a requirement and so we will try
to show you how to
easily apply some of the methods on the
platform first without
any technical requirements for coding
but then if you want to understand how
those methods work you can actually
open up that code and see what does the
code say
and how to modify it so that it works on
your data
producing the results that you can work
with
so before we go on i wanted to make sure
that i'm addressing any of the questions
that are starting to appear in your mind
so if you have any questions again the
best way to
post them is to put them in the chat
as you post them i will start addressing
them at specific breaks that i'll take
throughout this presentation and so in
the future presentation
the same process will happen we will
first address some of the questions that
you have posted on the forum or by email
if they are relevant for everybody in
the session
then we will review the material that we
have covered in
online courses and then we will do some
practical
exercises together so again if you have
any questions
as i am speaking you can post them in
the in the chat box and i will address
them
as we go through the slides so how
is this online coursework organized the
transcriptomics program
is really covering the material that is
found in transcriptomics
one two three and four and this is
a collection of courses that is
an increasing progression of difficulty
but also what's called downstream
processing steps
when you start with the data it has to
be generated
and so the generation of data what that
data represents
how that data is processed so how to get
it from its original digital format
into a table of gene expression is
covered in transcriptomics one
then we will talk about statistical
analysis so that statistical analysis
helps us understand
the specific patterns and how they might
be associated with
phenotypic information we have about our
samples
so we'll talk about differential gene
expression factor analysis
and how to use regression to evaluate
associations between gene expression
profiles
and the factors in our experiment design
in transcriptomics 3 we will talk about
what's called
big data analysis and big data analysis
opens up the opportunity for application
of data mining
and classification to gene expression
data
gene expression data is what's called
continuous data
and we will look at how to explore
that type of data for specific patterns
using principal component analysis and
clustering
but also how to train a machine
learning model to develop what's called
predictive analysis using
classification in transcriptomics 4
we will talk about single cell
transcriptonics or single cell
rna-seq where we will talk about how to
apply some of the similar methods but in
a different way
to the problem of zero-inflated data
which comes from thousands of cells that
are sequenced
individually within these courses
you will find a video introduction
and you will also find a curriculum that
helps guide
you as you go through the material so
for example you will find
uh in transcriptomics one uh a
basic explanation of uh transcription
and translation
but also will provide you some controls
and so some of you were asking about
notes uh here in the top menu you will
find
uh some of the resources that you can
take
with you so this will include a course
outline
you can search for specific sections and
you can also
access a lesson forum so each one of
these lessons has a forum
and also download the pdf so if you want
to take these materials with you
you can download the lesson pdf and go
through that
when you are offline now the
course materials are available
as a downloadable pdf but that is going
to be limited because
in the actual course material you will
find
specific terminology so terms that are
important
as you go through the full sequence of
this training
uh terms that are important for you to
remember
you will find them underlined like this
and you can hover over
to get a definition of that term so
it will help you understand all of the
material
without having to look up those terms
inside all of these courses there are
practical assignments
and so these practical assignments will
help you understand
what we are talking about in a practical
way how to apply these methods
to data sets so here for example you can
see
a hands-on assignment for
transcriptomics one
you will have some time to go through
this assignment so once you
are starting that time is going to start
and then you have a passing grade so
there will be some very specific
types of assignments here and those
assignments
will include some running of pipelines
on the t bioinfo platform so let me show
you
how this platform works
so to see how this platform works you
need to go
to server dot t dash bio
dot info and for those of you that have
completed the registration
you should be able to access this
account
using a password and an email address
that was emailed to you
so here i know that i am logged in i can
hover over
this icon right here and see that my
name is
right there and once you are in you will
have access to different
sections of this platform so please let
me know
how many of you have found their way
onto this platform already maybe you can
put
one for those of you that are here
and are logged in and two
if you are having trouble getting access
to this platform but you have requested
access
so if you have if you don't have an
account you don't know how to log
in you can go right here to access and
fill out this form when you fill out
this form we receive this notification
and we have to give you uh access
uh based on your request okay so david
uh has trouble accessing so
uh pizza if you could please look into
that
okay david looks like you need to check
your email
okay great so for those of you that have
access
you should be able to follow the steps
that i'm going to
do here and and do them together with me
so the way to do this and we'll just do
a demo here real quick to just get a
sense of how this works
let's go you can see under ngs data
which is next generation sequencing data
you can see the section for
transcriptomics and this first section
is called rna-seq
chip parallel analysis of ngs and
microarray data
and do not click on this click on this
drop down arrow and you should see a
number of demo
uh pipelines that pop up
okay and here we will go through
this pipeline right here rna-seq cell
line project
once you're on this page you can start
clicking on buttons that are lit up
that are dark and have this yellow
border around them
so this is what we will go through in
this program we'll go through the steps
of
processing mapping and quantification
of gene expression levels and here you
have an example
pipeline that we will try to replicate
today
just so that we understand how this will
work
so the first logical step is
pre-processing essentially we are taking
the reeds that have different
main sequences that come from the
genetic material in our sample
and some technical sequences that
include adapters
and some of them will have all kinds of
other technical sequences so to process
these reads we need to eliminate all of
these technical sequences
and only leave the valid sequences
and so this is done by trim-o-matic
then we need to remove this unnatural
amplification that is biased
towards specific types of read sequences
and so that is called
pcr amplification you can see it's the
process of
after your genetic material is in the
flow cell there is a
phase for bridge amplification before it
goes
into the sequencer and that variation
could be
adjusted by going through the pcr clean
step
afterwards we are going to map the reads
that we have cleaned up
onto the transcriptome
so mapping on the transcriptome allows
us to identify the
start and the end position for each read
and create what's called a sam or a bam
file
so this file will contain the sequences
of the reeds
as well as the beginning and the end of
each read on
the reference genome how many of you
have a sense of
how long is the human genome so who
knows how long
is the human genome
okay so mg is saying 3 billion please
specify 3 billion what 3 billion pixels
3 billion meters
what are we talking about here
nucleotides okay great so that is almost
correct it's about 3.2 billion
nucleotides so individual letters in the
human genome
and so you can imagine how mapping or
finding the best position for that read
to be aligned to onto the reference
genome
is a time-consuming application so here
you can see that this will take some
time
after we have mapped those individual
reads onto the reference genome
we want to quantify them or understand
the levels
of expression how much of this
particular exon this particular
transcript or this particular gene do i
have in a
given sample so that gene expression
quantification step will produce what's
called an
expression table and we can measure
these levels of expression
in several different formats we can just
count how many reads do we have
and so that will be called read count or
we can normalize the read count
based on different properties either how
many reads we have
in total for each sample because the
numbers could be different
or also include the length of a gene
so if we have a very long gene or a very
short gene
the likelihood of that particular read
to fall onto that sequence
is greater and so we can account for
that as well
once we have quantified our expression
levels we need to end this pipeline so
just click on
end click ok and now you will see
a download pipeline output file section
which you can open
and find here some of the outputs
okay so just to get a sense how many of
you were
able to run this demo pipeline and you
see
the results
alright so mhc18
is saying yes okay francisco
excellent let's give it a moment for all
the rest of you that are maybe still
preparing the pipeline it should look
something like this
anyone else is anyone else getting
results or if
are you having any trouble going through
this
sequence
okay all right well let's move on
what exactly should i do
so ng
are you are you here on this screen
okay so click right here on this drop
down arrow
and go to this demo army seek cell line
project
once you click here you should view the
pipeline builder
do you see it
okay once you see this you click on
start
okay click on ok
and now you will see some additional
options
so the one we want to do is click on
trimomatic
pcr clean connected to bow tie
2t which is mapping on the transcriptome
and then rsem expression table
once you have completed these steps you
click on end
and then you should see this output data
right here
and don't worry we will go through all
of these steps and as you saw there are
many different options as we
went through this process of building
the pipeline so we'll discuss some of
these options and exactly
why do they matter and how do they
change the outputs that we see right
here
okay so just to give you a sense of how
this works right this will be included
in many of your assignments
and many of the things that we will do
in the interactive sessions we will
go through different pipelines we'll
discuss the different methods
and we'll also talk about the input and
the output file so that we understand
how do we get from
a sample a biological sample that
contains some extracted rna
all the way to a table of digital data
that we can quantify and now work in a
statistical way with the numbers that we
have
to understand how does that characterize
the samples that we
put into the sequencer
so as i mentioned there are going to be
assignments like this
and they're going to be practical
sessions well we will review the
assignments
and once we review those assignments you
will be able to submit the sessions
and so in those you will utilize this t
bio info platform now importantly this
platform is really built for biologists
and not
necessarily for bioinformaticians it's
important
because many times when people think
bioinformatics
we go to linux and we start
manuscripting from the
uh you know command line and not that
that's a bad way to do things it's a
good way to do things but
it precludes many biologists and
clinicians from
working with their own data and we want
to make sure that all of you get access
to tools that
you can use and actually get some
results from
different types of data sets because
unless we try to apply this technique to
many different types of data and try
many variations of the same pipelines
we will not appreciate the opportunities
to explore this data in greater detail
and really getting insights into the
biology that we are
studying from the data that we have
okay so in the pipeline there are many
different options
and from those of you that already have
access to this platform what you can do
is you can start exploring each one of
these
variations and see the different types
of
logical steps with the specific outputs
that you will get as a result and
ultimately
we want to understand what the data
describes in terms of biology so we'll
go from
the basic processing to statistical
analysis
to biological interpretation here you
can see
a pathway and this pathway helps us
understand how the differentially
expressed genes that we found
in the data set help explain some kind
of a
biological pathway that we can see right
here
now we'll also look at the outputs
of intermediate steps i already
mentioned the same and the bam file
so we'll visualize those same on the bam
files
we'll look at tables of expression and
we'll understand the variation in those
tables of expression
looking at them from different
perspectives again we're talking here
about
3.2 billion nucleotides about
25 000 genes and we'll look at
even more complex data sets where those
numbers will grow
so it's important to know how to
leverage the different types of tools
for
visualizing and exploring the data to
really understand what they need
now in the projects that we will explore
all of these techniques will help you
understand
how do you go from having access to data
or generating your own data
to gaining biological insights and in
different sections of the
transcriptomics course collection
these are broken down into these
specific courses transcriptomics one
will talk about processing
transcriptomics two will help us
understand
how to find genes that resemble a
meaningful variation based on our
understanding of our samples
but we will also talk about specific
ways of pre-processing the data
so that we can explore that variation
knowing the assumptions
that some of our methods of analysis
will
expect from the data so we'll also talk
about different types of
data mining and classification methods
that allow us to work with
large data sets that have maybe tens or
even hundreds of samples
explore the variation from without
having to go through each individual
gene because the variation is going to
be very complex
so we'll talk about examples of projects
that have a small number of samples and
that will establish your biological
understanding then we'll go to
larger numbers of samples where we will
face this challenge of big data
importantly
some of these methods are written in
r and in python so you don't have to
just stick to the platform once you
understand the logic of the analysis
and the expected outputs you want to go
behind the scenes
and understand how does that actually
work
and learn a little bit of coding it's
going to be extremely beneficial for any
of you that want to actually apply these
techniques
and so to help you get started and do
that
we have developed a resource called omix
logic code
playground and we will use that code
playground together
in the sessions that we will do so let's
go to code.omicslogic.com
okay so let's go to code
omixlogic.com
again here you should see your account
if you have already registered this is
actually a free resource so you can get
started here for
free anyone that doesn't have an account
yet you can just create your own account
with just an
email and a password once you are
in you will have access to these
courses okay so please let me know
once you see the courses that i am
looking at
in my on my screen
okay so just so that i have a sense of
how many of you are still there
okay um so david is saying you're not
able to log in following any link so
that's very unfortunate but the way that
you do this
is you click on get started um
and here you can create an account
right here
okay so for those of you that already
have an account and maybe david if you
are having trouble after this session we
can just connect
separately and we will guide you through
on how to do this
okay so here you have some resources
again these resources are built so that
they could be incorporated into the
training that we have
and so they will be related methods of
analysis
don't you can explore this on your own
just kind of any resource that you want
to start with
but specifically what we will do in this
program is going to be
uh reviewed right here so we'll start
from loading data how to load in a table
of expression and understand
what kind of variables we're dealing
with
we'll go to data visualization and we'll
see how to make
bar plots and all kinds of box plots
and scatter plots we'll
look at dimensionality reduction
uh which helps us explore
uh variability in samples based on
a table of expression and we'll see how
to do that
and just to give you a sense of how this
will work
again you can take a look at this on
your own but how this will work
we will go through this interactive
experience
where in a session we will go through
a piece of code understand what it does
all right excellent david i'm happy to
hear that and then
we will go through what the input file
is how do we prepare it
for analysis and then what are the
specific
functions that we have to do to the data
to get the results and then you can just
simply click
run
okay and actually here we probably don't
need this
let me see
okay something happened here with
[Music]
okay there so we can run
this code right here in the browser
and once you understand this code you'll
be able to modify it
so that you understand what are these
outputs so if we look right here on pca
plots
we'll talk about well what is the
biological or biomedical significance
of being able to look at the gene
expression data to understand
what are the different types of breast
cancer that we are
looking at right here okay
again this is something that you can
start exploring on your own
and as we go through this content
in the interactive sessions we will
guide you
to specific assignments that once you
complete them
again so here you can see that i have
next and you will be able to complete
this lesson
and that will all be tracked under your
personal account
so you'll get points for completing some
of these exercises
for those of you that are going to apply
this to different types of data sets
we will also discuss on how to now
modify the code in the session and then
take this code with you and open this up
in your own application like our studio
or an environment like our studio so
how to install it how to get it set up
how to get your working directory set up
so that you can run this on the data
sets that you have
on your own computer again if you have
any questions as we're walking through
this
please do let me know now
importantly on this playground
we will be able to visualize data
we'll be able to understand what this
data variation
means in terms of biological
significance
and we will also talk about a variety of
different applications that are very
standard to the process of the rna-seq
processing analysis and visualization so
as we go through this process you'll
find tools
that are described as a general method
for example clustering is a general
method or box plot is a general
visualization method but also
specifically what does it mean
in the context of rna-seq data analysis
so
some specialized methods like
differential gene expression analysis
or annotation of differentially
expressed genes
for gene ontology terms and
pathway analysis will also be included
so for example one of the things that we
will do
is we will go through the pipeline that
combines
processing and differential gene
expression and then we'll see how to
create
your volcano plot and even heat maps so
that you can
not only understand what's in the data
but also present your results to others
as i mentioned at the end of this
process you will see how
processing and analysis of bulk rna-seq
is changing as we enter into this era of
single cell data analysis now single
cell
rna-seq has been really the result
of the last decade you can see that one
of the first methods was published in
2009
so we're really talking about less than
10 years or
just over 10 years ago and since then
the number of methods has
grown tremendously so the methods became
more and more sophisticated more and
more
automated and today we're looking at a
number of established methods that we
need to understand
how they work and what do they mean and
single cell transcriptomics
really is focused on identifying
all messenger rnas that are present in a
single
cell unlike bulk rna-seq profiling where
sequencing libraries are generated from
thousands of cells single cell
technologies
isolate cells and generate cell specific
sequencing libraries
so we need to know the barcodes for each
one of the libraries
which gives us a special technical
process
to prepare the data and then also
produces
a table of gene expression that is very
different from your bulk rna-seq because
you have
thousands or maybe hundreds of cells and
many of the genes
are just going to be zero because we
don't have as much genetic material
coming from a single cell
as opposed to a bulk data set that we
have
so that's where a lot of the methods for
preparing the data
and then working with the output tables
are going to be different
but theoretically and logically they
will be based on similar steps but we'll
go through that process
towards the end of the program now when
we speak about the application
of these different methodologies we have
to understand that let's say in
biomedical discovery
they also help us view the process the
biological process that we are studying
at different levels we can look at
patient-derived cell lines where we have
a lot of control on how the cells look
and how they function together
but really do not represent the systems
aspect because they are just individual
cells
when we look at patient-derived
xenograph models
we are looking at a host like a mouse
with a
grafted-in tumor that comes from the
patient but ultimately
our interest is to understand how can we
study these
phenotypic variations at the patient
population level and so that's where we
will see
the connection between different types
of data
different types of methodologies to work
with these models
and then ultimately how to interpret
them using different types of data sets
so we'll look at
ncbi where we can get a lot of
patient-derived cell line data
and patient-derived genograph models and
we'll look also at data sets like
tcga the cancer genome atlas that really
has a
well-characterized multi-omics data
repository for different types of
patient cohorts and
we'll see how access to such data
as well as the development of the
specific tools
and methods that we will discuss in this
program have really
changed different types of applications
for example
breast cancer classification has changed
over the
past decade tremendously because of
these molecular technologies and we'll
discuss
how that is happening and also discuss
how we are still not there we have not
cracked the code for some of these
diseases or many of these diseases in
fact because the biology
is so complex however
we will talk about some of the
applications of machine learning
for this type of molecular data
which helps us really understand how
rna-seq
and similar technologies are changing
the face of precision medicine so we'll
talk about
modeling precision medicine and we'll
have a data set that we'll work through
to identify the relationship between rna
expression
and prescription of different therapies
based on an example project in that
project we'll not only learn about the
actual
technical terms but we'll also go
through some of the
terminology that you will encounter in
typical publications on
in this field and it's important because
ultimately
you would want to go back to the
publications that are being discussed in
the media that are being discussed in
the research world in the academic world
and the industry
and to really understand what each one
of these terms means and so
we'll see specifically how all of these
methods
are and visual representations of the
outputs from these methods
are going to become much more clear
after you go through this program
now i did mention that i will be just
one of the presenters
together with me we have a team uh dr
will also be involved in some of the
sessions as well as
project discussions at the end of this
program so it's important that you you
can find them they're here on the chat
together with us they will play
different roles um as we go through the
program
the training program itself uh but
as you develop a sense of how
the rna-seq data is analyzed you'll
start thinking about how to apply this
data to your
own project and that's really where i
see them being
most helpful is helping you determine
how to go from training to independent
research and we have multiple
opportunities
to go through uh public uh publicly
available data sets
to go through some of the research
papers that you might be interested in
and discuss how to apply this data to
a project of your own we'll guide you
through that project in one of the last
sessions that we'll have
but as you start going through the
sessions that we discuss here if you
have any questions about that or you
have specific ideas that you would like
to discuss
please do reach out so for dr harpreet
kawar her email is support
pine dot bio you can also email her
any of the questions that you might have
at the technical level
and for dr mohit mazumdar
who also has a phd in computational
biology his email is
mohit pine dot pyo thank you bibsa so if
you have
any questions related to different types
of programs that we have
different which includes a research
fellowship that you can join to work
on an independent project or you have
questions about how to
find and organize your data for
independent analysis you can reach out
to him
and any technical
materials access to different types of
accounts different platforms that we
discussed today
you can reach out to beeps of biswas her
email is marketing at pine.bio
and she will be sending you a lot of the
information about this program
and about the different resources that
we have prepared so please
put her in your contact list so that you
don't miss out on those important emails
she will be also emailing you about some
of the
recordings or not some but all of the
recordings that we have for these
sessions
so after the session is over you will
have to wait a little bit
and then you'll get a link by email and
also on the forum
about the recorded version uh now all
uh all of our team has gone through
the same training like we are discussing
here and so we
are familiar with the materials and the
different assignments and the quiz
questions
so please feel free to reach out to us
and we hope that as a result of this
program
you will also feel more empowered and
able to analyze your own data
and we are looking forward to working
with you to identify how we can best
support that
process from our side now briefly
uh let me pause here for any questions
if you have any questions
put them in the chat box and then i want
to uh
talk a little bit about the different
projects that we will cover
in this session
uh hi elia uh if i may uh say
and address a few things uh so i know
that i have sent
all the registered participants an email
on all the resources that elia has
discussed today
now one thing that i wanted to point out
is that we have three different
platforms as you see one is the
educational platform for the
different asynchronous courses and
they're also a synchronous projects
and the forum and the second is the
tbinfo server platform
and the third is the codemix logic
platform now all of you must have
received an email
on tbio info access from me that is
only for login to the tbi info platform
and it's not applicable for the edu
platform or the codomix logic platform
and then you will be able to use your
single email whatever email you have
registered for in the program
for the other two sites which is the edu
platform which most of you have access
to as well as for the codomix logic
if you're not able to log into the
codomix logic please create
a new account for yourself and in case
you have any problem please reach out to
me again
and i will be able to help you out with
that process
and again thank you so much for
attending today's session and elia back
to you
okay thank you beeps okay
so before we actually uh continue to
talk about projects
um let us briefly
ask you to also join our community so as
i mentioned
this is a program to help you learn
and master rna-seq we have other
programs that include
non-training programs include free
resources as well as
our research and so
we ask that you also join us
on our onyx logic group
on linkedin if you have a uh
group if you have a linkedin account or
a facebook account
beeps if you could please uh paste those
links
um okay so uh you will find there a lot
of the resources
um okay let me just go there real quick
okay thank you yeah so we have here um
the omixlogic group
where we have over 700 members and we
regularly post here some of the results
of this training so you'll see for
example
student projects that have joined uh the
training programs without any background
or experience in bioinformatics
and have been able to develop really
impressive research projects
using some of the tools and the methods
that we discussed
so really looking forward to interacting
with you not only
in the program but also beyond
okay there was a question if there are
some free courses with certificates
uh dr kumar singh is asking so
dr kumar we do have um
some free resources that you will get
certificates for
and also for anyone we do
ask that you help us understand
a little bit more about you and the best
way to do this is to finish our
introduction to bioinformatics course
the introduction to bioinformatics
course is free for anyone to take
it also includes introductions to some
of the methodologies that we will cover
but importantly it will guide you
through a
uh a survey where you will be able to
share a little bit more details about
yourself uh
and we're looking forward to
understanding more about your
background level uh your interests
as well as where you are located so
please start with this free course and
you will find some of the other courses
on this educational platform
you also will find some materials for
coding that are free on the code
omixlogic.com and all of that material
together
is going to be available on our page
called
learn.omixlogic.com which you could also
explore
by going here the same account is going
to work here as well
okay so let's briefly summarize what we
have talked about and talk a little bit
about the different projects
that you can learn about these different
methods and their applications
by going through these projects there
are many different applications of
rna-seq
including a lot of the different cancer
projects
including neurodegenerative diseases and
even agriculture
so we do ask that you review some of
these materials
and think about how you can go through
some of this
type of data on your own now importantly
some of you are asking about the
research fellowship the research
fellowship
is a program that will help you go
beyond training and apply the tools to a
data set of your own
in this program it is a three or a six
month research fellowship program uh
it is not free but there are
scholarships available
uh if you uh if you have experience and
you already have a defined project
uh you can apply for a scholarship uh
the scholarship also applies for the
training as well uh so beeps if you
could share the link to
uh the scholarship request form
now the research fellowship after you've
understood how rna-seq
works you might want to develop a
project of your own and that will take
significant time
so three to six months is typically what
it takes depending on the complexity
and how you how prepared you are already
for the coursework
uh vipsap if you could please uh thank
you
uh well no if you could post the uh
request for scholarship form
okay so previously we have numerous
participants that have
completed the training went on to
develop a project of your own and have
presented those
at different types of international
workshops
and poster sessions now in the days of
the pandemic
this is especially meaningful because so
many of these
are happening online so it's an
opportunity for you to
learn more about these international
sessions as well
and really develop something that is
impactful
we also hope that some of the materials
that we discuss in these sessions
go beyond just learning and
uh you know kind of practice projects
but as you can see
different researchers have joined these
programs to
also apply uh the same approaches to
clinical impactful projects
and we hope that you know we can
facilitate that as well for some of you
so if we
know more about you we know more about
how to help you
we can guide you to the resources that
will be
most meaningful to uh your personal
development right so whether it's a
career path
whether you are interested in training
your students and helping your students
understand how to utilize rna-seq data
if it is development of a research
project or even
applying that research to a real
research problem so we have different
resources and tools that are available
for that as well
so in summary in this program you'll
learn about
rna-seq data processing analysis and
interpretation
will leverage cloud-based tools that
will allow you to go
quickly through some of the complex
pipelines that are typically used in
rna-seq
experiments you'll see where machine
learning fits in
to this large biomedical data set
analysis
paradigm and you'll be able to complete
and present an independent research
project if you have enough time
and obtain a certificate of completion
or certificate of excellence and you'll
be able to showcase that
on your social media profiles etc
so we are excited about this program
that is starting
if you have any questions uh please
follow up with us
by email or on the forum if you're
already registered
and in our next session we'll start
talking about the process
of preparation of the data and
data processing what are some of the
options that we saw in today's pipeline
and what are some of the differences and
outputs that we expect
from different processing pipelines
again my name is elia brodsky i'll be
here
in all of the sessions or most of the
sessions but also
thank you beeps for joining today and
helping with the session
and dr harpreed or mohit
if you have anything to add feel free to
add now
yeah hello everyone um myself dr mohit
and i'll be happy to help you with this
uh
process of learning transitioning from
hands-on
exercises and theoretical aspects to a
research project
so p please feel free to reach out to me
happy to help thank you
thank you corporate would you like to
say a few words yeah
hello everyone my name is harpreet so
i'm going to take you some of the assist
you during all those sessions
so even if you face any issue regarding
any course or any assignment
during all those courses transcriptomics
courses so you can
mail me at sport at pine bio as already
india has um given that
you to in the chat box so you are feel
free uh
please feel free to any uh regarding any
query
if you face any issue regarding any
courses or the assignments
okay so thank you everyone
all right thank you dr harpreet kawar
and we'll see all of you in our next
session on friday
december 11th at the same time so these
session
links will be emailed to you um and
you'll be able to also see the details
of what is the topic
of the next session uh
on the forum uh and uh
the feedback uh link uh dr uh
kumar singh is asking for a feedback
link i don't know beeps if you have one
please share with them as well thank you
everyone for joining and we look forward
to seeing you again
in our next session